david castillo autor intelectual del
asesinato de la líder ambientalista
hervás cáceres fue sentenciado este día
a 22 años seis meses de prisión por un
tribunal de sentencia a clic en the
musical
castillo era el director general de la
empresa de esade honduras encargada de
la construcción de una represa sobre las
aguas del río huancar que vio sido
considerado sagrado por los indígenas la
sentencia fue leída en presencia de las
hijas y demás familiares de berta
cáceres así como los integrantes de esta
organización es popular e indígena que
fue fundada por berta cáceres y que se
encargaba de defender los derechos de
los indígenas ahora la organización es
dirigida por su hija bertha cáceres
aunque esta sentencia fue celebrada por
el pueblo indígena según ellos todavía
falta que se lleve a la justicia a más
autores intelectuales entre ellos
podrían estar involucrados empresarios
gente del gobierno y de las fuerzas
armadas de honduras